bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors tout d'abord cette
violation du cessez le feu qui a été
signalée par l'armée russe était
surprenante c'est mou
bonjour pas vraiment je trouve
d'ailleurs que depuis l'accord du 10
novembre jusqu'à maintenant il ya eu
très peu d'incidents donc quand on sort
on sait que les arméniens ont dû
abandonner leur maison et qu'ils ont
détruites que les azerbaïdjanais ont
retardé l'échéance de l'accord du 10
novembre pour la récupération de du
district de kelbadjar on sait que
cessez-le-feu et l'installation du
cessez-le-feu est toujours difficile
donc d incidents de ce type sont sont
quasiment normaux si je puis dire en
tout cas prévisibles
justement le président turc recep tayyip
erdogan qui ne cache pas son soutien à
l'azerbaïdjan avait d'ailleurs appelé à
lutter jusqu'au bout à continuer la
lutte pour récupérer les terres qui sont
encore sous contrôle arménien a est ce
que vous pensez que voilà aussi voilà la
turquie elio pour quelque chose en tout
cas avec ses ses provocations qu'on voit
aujourd'hui ce que je crée difficile à
dire ce qui est sûr c'est que la jungle
agenda turc n'est pas exactement le même
que l'agenda de de l'azerbaïdjan le le
président aliev a rempli en quelque
sorte son contrat vis-à-vis de son
peuple puisqu'il a récupéré l'essentiel
des terres et que le statut de du haut
karabakh sera défini plus tard par
lui-même en fait par l'azerbaïdjan donc
lui la rampe pratiquement 90 % de sa de
sa tâche si je puis dire historique
puisque en fait la dynastie des reliefs
a été porté au pouvoir pour récupérer le
haut karabakh donc ça c'est l'agenda de
d'aliev l'agenda de deux ans à perdre
aux hans et de de récupérer son
influence sur l'ensemble du caucase qui
n'est pas exactement la même chose donc
dans l'accord du 10 novembre il n'est
pas fait mention de la turquie les
discussions sont toujours en cours mais
on devine que le résultat ne sera pas
favorable à la turquie en ce qui
concerne la présence de soldats turcs
sur le terrain et je pense que si elle y
est fasciné l'accord du 10 novembre
alors que la turquie n'est pas mentionné
ce n'est pas totalement un hasard donc
nous avons deux agendas différents
quant à savoir si la la turquie est
derrière les violations cessez le feu
il ya tellement de deux circonstances
qui peuvent susciter des violations
cessez le feu qu'il est très difficile
de se prononcer alors après c'est ces
violations ont été observés par l'armée
heureuse bakwa a dénoncé des
provocations a longtemps il a demandé
des contre-mesures comment justement
bakou pourrait-elle voilà répondre à ces
attaques
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y ait des
attaques quand quand il ya une violation
de cessez le feu notre show tendance à
dire que c'est l'adversaire qui a
commencé moi je crois plutôt à des
incidents de en fait c'est un corps
comme tous les accords est un accord
qu'il ne qui ne satisfait pas pleinement
les deux parties on sait très bien que à
bas coût il ya des gens qui pensent que
aliev a trop cédé qu'il aurait dû
récupérer le haut karabakh est allé
jusqu'au bout de son combat
et quant à l'arménie on sait très bien
que bas chinian est en difficulté et
qu'il a une opposition qui demande son
départ à cause de cette défaite donc
personne n'est pleinement content et
c'est là qu'intervient évidemment le
comment dirais-je le
le médiateur avec les forces présentes
qui sont des forces russes qui sont là
sans doute pour longtemps et qui doivent
réguler en fait un double mécontentement
sur un fond quand même deux comme gage
de nécessité d'une paire ressenti en
tout cas par les arméniens
et je pense aussi du côté de en tout cas
la liesse sovo le corps vont durer
malgré cette première violation
c'est la responsabilité de défense de
maintien de la paix russes ils ont pris
les moyens je crois de le faire dans
l'accord c'est pratiquement deux mille
hommes 90 blindés tout ça je pense que
la russie a les moyens de d'imposer le
cessez le feu même si c'est sans doute
pas la dalle à la dernière violation du
cessez-le-feu auquel on assiste
merci beaucoup au genre de gliniasty
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur de
recherche à l'iris institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques